good morning it's seven o'clock you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster two big stories
this morning the latest on tiger woods
after his car crash we're live at the
hospital
plus a new plan to help school children
catch up over the summer
the nml news on exams we'll be asking
the education secretary in a few
moments time also this morning we're
going to be putting your questions on
the vaccine roll out
to england's deputy chief medical
officer jonathan van tam he joins us
at nine o'clock for 30 minutes of your
questions
and charles darwin's treasures we
explore
what's been unearthed at quarter tonight
it's wednesday the 24th of february
lucky to be alive new details of tiger
woods injuries are revealed following
his car crash
in los angeles i've seen fatal traffic
collisions
so um i will say that it's very
fortunate that mr woods um
was able to come out of this life
no quick fixes a warning as new plans to
help school children catch up over
summer are revealed
and sky news special investigation into
football academies and what happens to
the young players who don't make the cut
i was taking days off work because i was
absolutely convinced that that was the
day he was going to take his life
diy smear test the cervical screening
trial for tens of thousands of women
that hopes to tackle delays during the
pandemic
and as we head into the weekend high
pressure bills allowing for mostly fine
and dry conditions but
today there is risk of flooding with
some rather persistent downpours of rain
i have the details for you later
good morning police say he's lucky to be
alive the first four details of tiger
woods injuries have been revealed in the
last
hour following his car crash in los
angeles
in just a moment we'll be live at the
hospital where the golfer has undergone
emergency surgery and is now awake and
responsive
uh us correspondent cordelia lynch
reports
this is the car that golfing legend
tiger woods had to be pulled from in los
angeles just after seven o'clock
yesterday morning it rolled several
times after careering off the road and
landing on a grassy verge
the 45 year old was driving alone when
the vehicle flipped
this is audio of the dispatch call
hey ma'am do we have an uh fire we have
a rollover
the man first on the scene said tiger
woods was
conscious lucid and calm and extremely
lucky to have survived i have seen many
collisions
the the nature of his vehicle the fact
that he was wearing a seatbelt
i i would say that it greatly increased
the
likelihood that it saved his life i will
say that it's very fortunate that mr
woods
was able to come out of this alive
he'd only just undergone his fifth back
surgery
and wasn't playing competitively while
he recovered
but he'd been in california to host the
genesis
invitational golf tournament and spent
time
with other sports stars how good am i or
how bad am i
good i'm not good
i'm sorry for you we're getting better
22 years on from the first green jacket
comes the fifth
woods achieved one of the greatest
comebacks in sporting history in 2019
winning the masters he'd been hoping to
compete
again this year this recent huge setback
left friends deeply unsettled i mean i'm
sick to my stomach
uh you know it hurts to
see one of your i mean now my closest
friends um
you know getting an accident and man i
just hope he's all right
just uh just worry for his kids you know
i'm sure they're struggling
the la county sheriff says there was no
evidence tiger wood was impaired at the
time of this crash
and he's currently being treated at
harbor ucla
medical center the former world number
one who made it back to the top
against the odds now has another fight
on his hands
cordelia lynch sky news washington
well let's talk now to our correspondent
sally lotwood she joins us now from the
medical center in
los angeles and sally what's the latest
we know about tiger woods condition
well tiger woods was brought here
because his injuries appeared so
serious and this is a trauma center but
it's a relief to hear
an update from his team on his official
twitter account
that he is awake and responsive and
recovering
in his hospital room a little more
detail for you they
wrote in this statement he's undergone a
long surgical procedure on his
lower right leg and ankle after being
brought to the hospital
open fractures affecting both the upper
and lower portions of the tibia
and fibula bones were stabilized by
inserting a rod into the tibia
additional injuries to the bones of the
foot and ankle was stabilized with a
combination of screws
and pins now as we've heard tiger woods
was very lucky to survive
uh this incident according to emergency
responders who attended
uh at the scene uh but of course at the
masters
is around six weeks away and the big
question was whether he was going to
make it of course after five
uh operations on his back that was
already looking unlikely
uh it's now of course very unlikely
indeed that he will make
uh that tournament after that incredible
comeback in 2019
uh the stuff of a film many are
describing it
but his supporters and fans are very
very happy to hear that he
is okay making uh a recovery and of
course as many say
never underestimate tiger woods for
making a comeback
yeah big relief for many that he is
hopefully on the road to that recovery
sally thank you very much for the update
and there's a new plan to help school
children catch up over the summer but
education leaders are warning that there
are no
quick fixes to so much a disrupted
education well let's get more on this
we're joined now by the education
secretary gavin williamson thank you for
being on the program
can you just talk us through what to
expect from this announcement what
exactly should parents be expecting
well this is a added boost to education
and to children we recognize that all
children
have missed out on so much over the last
year and that's why
uh just six months ago we announced the
one billion pound uh
catch-up fund but on top of that we're
putting an extra
700 million pounds into this this will
see
extra money 200 million pounds going to
secondary schools to
roll out uh summer lessons and summer
camps if that's what the route they want
to do part expansion of our national
tutoring program so we can really target
resources to those
children who need it most to give them
that extra boost
to help them catch up on some of the
classroom time
that they've missed but we've got to
recognize but
you talked about the uh most
disadvantaged children and
being targeted at them but some people
are going to be wondering if this is
enough i mean 10 years of progress
between closing the gap between the most
disadvantaged and more privileged peers
has been wiped out according to the
education endowment fund this
apparently works out at about six
thousand pounds per primary school
is it enough should you not be looking
at more drastic measures like
lengthening school days
or shortening the school holiday so
we're looking at a whole sort of range
of different actions but what we wanted
to do is to give
schools the extra resources that they
needed to be able to take action
immediately
some of the reforms that we want to look
at
and sort of consult on we'll sort of
look at the whole expanse of what we can
do in terms of helping children
have extra teaching time have extra
opportunities
but this is an immediate response to
give those children that extra boost
but the best support we can do is seeing
children back into the classroom on the
8th of march
which is i think something that all
parents want to see
all children want to see and teachers
want to see as well
so just to pick up that you're saying
you're consulting on a whole range of
things about extending teaching time
does that mean you are
looking at extending the school day well
we recently appointed sir kevin collins
in order to be
able to look at how we do education
recovery
a man who's had so many years of
experience and we're looking at a whole
range
a broad range of different options of
how we can support
schools how we can support teachers but
most importantly how we can support
children
and that's a whole range including
lengthening the school day
uh well he will be looking at how we can
boost and support children in a whole
range of different
manners but it's not just about uh it's
not just about time in school it's about
supporting teachers in terms of the
quality of teaching and how we can help
them
okay sounds like it is on the table
though um i just want to ask about the
timing of this announcement as well this
extra top-up money
um children have experienced right now
338 days
of disrupted education since they were
closed in that first lockdown and i just
wonder
if this feeds into you know a wider
theme if you
effectively just doing things too late
at the last minute after they've already
become obvious i mean
you announced more laptops for schools
for example back in
april many still don't have them now you
know beginning of january the exams
were going to be cancelled without
announcing a plan of what was going to
replace them i mean are you basically
you know the essay crisis education
secretary you know you only do things
right at the last minute and you leave
other people to pick up the pieces
so what we announced is a billion pound
fund in terms of boosting children's
education giving them extra help and
support and schools that extra help and
support
uh over six months ago uh this is the
extra action that we're taking because
ashley's children have suffered more
disruption as a result of that
we always recognize that the best form
of assessment for children
was through exams but when we're in a
situation where we had to
lock down schools again and we weren't
being able to welcome children into
schools
we did have to take another route we've
made it clear that that's through
teacher judgment and teacher assessment
as to how those grades will be awarded
and our focus is very much in terms of
welcoming children back
on the 8th of march it's an incredibly
important part of
our unlocking of the country but it's
also goes to confirm the priority that
the prime minister and i have always
said the national priority is our
children and their education
we've always said schools would be the
last to close and first to open and
we've been absolutely true to our work
so what is your plan then to replace
exams you say that you recognize it's
the best form of teacher
assessment how are you going to replace
them well what we already
set out um in sort of the first week of
january is the fact that we'd be
uh putting uh teacher judgment at the
core of it it would be
teacher assessed grades uh that would be
uh
what uh is the basis of gcses and a
levels
uh we're in the next few days going to
be outlining the details
uh further details of the plan following
the consultation that we carried out
with the sector
that had one of the largest responses
that uh of any consultation that we've
ever run
i understand you know you need to
consult you need to get this right
because it's so important but what i
don't understand is when exams were
cancelled last year when it was entirely
predictable that they could be cancelled
again this year
why didn't you announce a comprehensive
plan at the same time
as announcing that they were going to be
cancelled it would really help parents
and children as well
and the anxiety levels well as you
probably recall back in january we did
set out very clearly that we're moving
to
uh teacher judgement in terms of
assessment
and grades but no details about how
they're going to be moderated
and we absolutely rightly wanted to
consult on this we'll be setting out for
details
incredibly shortly in the next few days
and you'll have to sort of uh
just wait a short time longer before we
set out more details on that
but the best form of assessments has
always been examination
that's why we had felt that the best
route has
many other countries uh right around for
the world even
while they've been dealing with the
pandemic could also reach that same
conclusion
uh but um in terms of a changing
situation
uh we felt is right to be able to
consult on a different route
and sort of set out our contingency
plans in terms of doing that that's what
we did
we completed the consultation and we'll
be informing
both children teachers and parents have
resorted to that incredibly soon
contingency plan does that mean people
could still have sick exams then
no no okay um i'm interested to hear
about universities
as well they're not included they
weren't included in the roadmap this
week can you guarantee
to university students that they're
going to get some face-to-face teaching
uh by the end of this academic year well
i i do apologize to correct you
but they were actually included as part
of a roadmap and actually what you're
seeing
is uh from the eighth of uh from the
eighth of march you'll be seeing all
practical
students uh been able to return that's
roughly about uh
40 percent of all students studying at
university so
a very significant increase in the
number of students that are going to be
going back to university
i equally recognize that there's many
more students that
are not covered in that that's why as
part of the next stage there is a
review about when we can bring two
students back into university as the
earliest possible moment
um this is the right time to do so
um i certainly want to be seeing uh
students back into the
university at the earliest possible
moment that's why you're conducting a
review
and that's why we're going to be
welcoming so many back on the 8th of
march
as you say the majority of students
we're still not clear when they're going
to return can you guarantee that all
university students will have some
face-to-face teaching this academic year
yeah we want to be seeing all uh
students whatever courses
they're doing to be having face-to-face
teaching this year that's why we're
setting up the review point of the
next stage of a roadmap as to when we're
going to be able to make
absolutely clear that uh all students
are going to be able to return back to
university
okay now james wharton the former
conservative mp someone you know very
well obviously because she both worked
together
on boris johnson's leadership campaign
he's been appointed the head
of the independent regulator for higher
education
in england can you just talk me through
what experience he's got in that sector
because i mean oh
i've had a look i can't really find any
well james brings an immense amount of
experience both as a government minister
as a lawyer before entering uh
parliament
but also as a chairman of a
business and uh bringing business
experience as well as public service
experience into that role
and what he will be is an incredibly
strong voice and champion
uh for students as well as the sector
making sure that we drive up standards
in the sector
making sure that we uh drive up the
quality of what students get from
universities and helping uh you know
the sector deliver real change in terms
of what they deliver in terms of student
experience
and i think we need to have strong
advocates
in organizations such as the office for
students
there's a absolutely rightly there to
hold universities to account and i have
no doubt
that he will do exactly that as he did
in his ministerial career
well i'm glad that you've got no doubt
because other people have got some
doubts
on this and you know he's been given
this very
lucrative role sixty thousand pound a
year for two days a week
in the university sector when i asked
what relevant
experience in that sector you've got you
said he's been a minister and a lawyer i
mean you can understand why some people
might think hang on a minute
is this just jobs for the boys well
actually
so many of these incredibly important
public appointments is making sure that
you have strong advocates for the sector
making sure that you have strong strong
voices for students that is what uh
lord wharton will be and i have no doubt
that he will take
the enthusiasm and the passion that he
always had whether as a
differed minister whether as a minister
for the northern powerhouse
into that exact same role in terms of
advocating for universities
and advocating for students making sure
that we drive a quality agenda
in terms of making sure that teaching uh
within universities continues to improve
these are all things that are absolutely
vital that the office for students does
and this follows an extensive
independent uh
sort of recruitment process and one
where he was also interviewed by the
select committee
in parliament which also endorsed his
import appointment as well
very quickly because we are at a time um
but this comes off the back
of other people who are known to the
this government being awarded
lucrative contracts and for example
neighborhood hancock getting 30 million
pounds to produce files for covert tests
we really meant to believe that this is
all just complete coincidence that they
have relationships with members of
government and they were really
appointed because they were the best
people for the job
we always appoint for people who are
best person for the job driving the
government's agenda in terms of change
and reform whether that's in
universities whether that's in schools
whether that's in uh any other sector of
society because actually we want to
deliver change we want to deliver the
leveling up agenda
that's always the focus and our focus is
getting the best people
into those jobs to deliver that change
and help us deliver the agenda
that we were elected to deliver back in
2019.
okay gavin williamson thank you very
much for being on the program thank you
thank you for having me well let's bring
in our political correspondent tom
rayner a couple things to pick up on the
interview i thought it was quite
interesting that he didn't rule out
lengthening the school day it felt to me
that was something that was on the table
to try and help children catch up i
think what's really notable about the
announcement this morning
is that we are seeing more money but the
reaction from the education sector has
been
well this is promising but we need a lot
more and it seems that
what they're trying to get at is it's
not just about more money they obviously
want that but it's also a plan
and there hasn't really come with
this announcement a plan of what exactly
schools are expected to do with this
money there's talk of
lessons in the summer but no actual
specific instruction as to whether that
should be
teachers from the school itself whether
it's external agencies how that's going
to work how it's going to be organized
whether
schools are required to do that and so
when you were asking about the specifics
uh it's clear that
as they stand the education secretary
has this being worked on by
kevin collins and he certainly didn't
rule out things like
extending the school day or shortening
the holidays
but for now that's all still something
where there's a big question mark over
it and that is going to lead head
teachers and parents
and children into a situation where
they're still uncertain as to how things
are going to progress yeah you can
really see that uncertainty starting to
affect people and tom thank you very
much for uh they are says thank you very
much
reminder we're going to have a special
vaccines q a program with the deputy
chief medical officer professor jonathan
van tam that's at nine o'clock
so do join us for that
still to come on the show at quarter to
eight i'm going to be speaking to the
former teacher and writer at the times
education supplement graeme hallinan
about plans to help kids get back up to
speed
the hotel quarantine experience at 25 to
8 we're going to be speaking to a couple
nearing the end of their 10-day
isolation in heathrow hotel
plus in the next hour hopes for a green
light for driving tests in april we'll
speak to the chief executive
of the red driving school about the
backlog of tests and
lessons
well time now for a look at the
morning's other main stories the duke of
edinburgh remained in hospital this
morning after being admitted last week
with an infection but his son prince
edward has told our royal correspondent
rianna mills that his father
is a lot better just a little bit bored
i did speak to him the other day so he's
he's he's a lot better thank you very
much indeed and
and uh so and he's looking forward to
getting out which is which is the most
positive thing so
we keep our fingers crossed since
frustration at being in hospital
just a bit i think that gets to all of
us so and then
that uh so yeah you can you can only
watch the clock
so many times and and the walls are only
so interesting
the number of female top bosses in
britain's biggest firms has risen
sharply in recent years but more
progress is needed
that's according to a report from the
hampton alexander review which revealed
the number of women on ftse boards had
jumped by 50 percent in five years
that means around a third of ftse 350
board roles
are now held by women
tens of thousands of women will be able
to take smear tests at home for the
first time as part of a trial
it's hoped the move will encourage more
people to take the test and cut the
number of cervical cancer
cases well ender brady has more for us
and you can see why they want to do this
i would imagine that the number of smear
tests may have fallen during the
pandemic
but is there a worry about people
missing a serious
cancer yeah i think that's the the
reason behind this
um the the tests are going to be posted
out in the coming days and weeks to 31
000 women in the following areas so
london boroughs of baroness camden
islington newham and tower hamlets and
they will be sending them to women aged
25 to 64.
and these are primarily women who are 15
months
overdue a smear test a check so they'll
be posted out
uh the women will then send their
samples back
and they will be contacted with their
results so 31 000
home tests in total it's the first time
ever this has been trialled in the nhs
in england and i noticed this morning
that the eve appeal which is one of the
prominent gynecological cancer
charities in the country they say this
is potentially a
game changer so very very interesting
development indeed okay
and thank you very much for the update
thank you
now if you've been working from home you
might be able to get away with a looser
dress code but not
if you are an mp we now go
to we now go no
i don't think we do go to stoke on trent
the
the honorable gentleman has to be
dressed
as if he were here in the chamber
so we will not go to stroke on trent we
will go
we will try to come back to mr gullis
in due course
bit of a ticking off there from the
deputy speaker dame elena lang who
actually refused to talk to conservative
mp jonathan goulish for
not wearing a suit jacket mps are
expected to wear usual business dress
a tie though is not mandatory they don't
go that far
mr ghoulis was allowed to contribute
after he put on a jacket a few minutes
later
now in the last few moments the
education secretary gavin williamson
told the program that the government
is considering a broad range of options
when it asked him directly if school
days could be lengthened to help
students catch up on myths learning
it comes as the government announces
funding to help secondary schools run
summer lessons to make up for time away
from the classroom
i also press mr williamson on whether a
longer school day
is in the offing we're looking at a
whole range
a broad range of different options of
how we can support
schools how we can support teachers but
most importantly how we can support
children including that whole range
including lending the school day
uh well he will be looking at how we can
boost and support children in a whole
range of different
uh manners but it's not just about uh
it's not just about time in school it's
about supporting teachers in terms of
the quality of teaching
and how we can help them
gavin williamson uh speaking to me a
little bit earlier now the
travel and aviation sectors have been
among the hardest hit by the coronavares
pandemic
they were of course those among among
those listening carefully on monday
as the prime minister detailed the steps
that england would take to lift lockdown
restrictions well joining us now to
discuss that is owen jones the managing
director of wizard uk thank you so much
for
being with us i imagine that you like
everyone else in the country was
listening very closely
to the prime minister's statements on
easing lockdown restrictions
didn't seem like there was a clear
message to me on summer holidays though
how worried are you
yes very much we've been anticipating uh
the road map uh for some weeks now
and particularly how it's going to
affect aviation and travel as you say
uh we have some of the strictest trouble
restrictions uh in europe currently in
place in the uk
um but what we were asking for was it
was a road map out now we
we believe the government has to take a
risk-based approach um
we need to look at what the risks are
and how we can safely get people
traveling again i think from our
perspective
uh what we did get with some clarity at
least as far as england is concerned
that
we don't need to expect to plan for any
travel at least before the 17th of may
which
at least gave a little bit of clarity
for the industry to start its planning
process
we've heard stories about domestic
holidays getting booked up pretty
rapidly
what's it been like for the airline
industry are people actually
booking tickets or is it just not
happening at the minute
uh it has been a quiet booking period
certainly
during 2021 so far because people have
been unsure
about whether or not they're going to be
able to travel now that glimmer of hope
that we've had
that international travel is on the
agenda uh which we're very uh
thankful for uh and that uh not before
date of the 70th of may it certainly has
got people interested
and so we like other airlines have seen
a
considerable uptick in bookings uh
compared the last few weeks
for the travel period from say june
onwards um people i think are planning
ahead and taking the view
that uh given what's been announced by
the prime minister uh the likelihood is
that they are gonna be able to travel
um you said there's been an uptick in
bookings can you have you got any
numbers to give us a bit of perspective
on that
yeah i mean uh let's be honest i mean
we've seen lots of figures being thrown
out they're the hundreds percent we're
starting from a pretty low base
um but uh now i mean in terms of where
we go where we've been at in the last
week to compare where we've been just
the last two days so you know it's not a
big data set
um but certainly you know we're we're
two or three times what we were seeing
at this time last week okay you were
saying it's been a quiet
uh period that it's starting from a low
base of course that's no secret we know
that
um how have things been at wizard have
you been had to make redundancies
how difficult has it been uh well i
think what we've done at wiz air is
we've been very agile where we dealt
with the the pandemic
uh we did have a round of redundancies a
year ago um
not actually that many redundancies in
the uk but as a company
as we go into summer 2021 we're actually
going as a bigger company than we were
this time last year would be 40 bigger
in the uk going into the uh the summer
and we're creating around about 300 new
jobs flying 60 new routes
opening three new bases and more broadly
across the network in in europe we've
taken 17 brand new aircraft
in the last 12 months uh you know that's
about one and a half billion at least
prices uh we've opened 50 new bases
uh and added around about uh 260 new
routes so
uh for us we we've we've been agile
we've scaled up very quickly when we've
been able to that demand has been there
legally we've had the agility to scale
back down and keep our costs under
control
when more stringent restrictions have
come in of course it's a very difficult
time for the industry as a whole are we
going to see other operators going bust
do you think
um i think you know it has been a tough
year and yes we've seen some casualties
uh what we focused on and and you know
the interviews are focused on
uh is is its cost uh we went into the
crisis as one of the most financially
resilient
uh carriers in europe and and we're
going to come out to the crisis in the
same position
and that's because we've been very tight
on managing our cost
and and how we operated our routes
during the last year so we focused very
much
on only operating where there's demand
and we can do that in a way which brings
cash into the business okay i'm
interested to get your take on the hotel
quarantine
uh system as well we'll be talking to a
couple in a minute who
are stuck in a hotel preaching
approaching the end of their 10-day
quarantine period
how much of an issue is it and while
that quarantine exists are we really
going to see people
actually booking flights
yes and i think this is where people are
looking ahead so at the moment uh you
know as i say we have some of the
strictest
uh travel restrictions quality
restrictions of anywhere in europe
and now the government doing that for
public health reasons uh is basically on
the data that's basing on
science what we're urging the government
to do and what we want to do with the
government along with all the other
airlines in the uk
is look at the risk that we're uh we're
addressing when we restart international
travel
so hotel quarantine there yes it's there
for a reason at the moment
what we want to do is to work with the
government to look at why it's there and
as we expand uh international travel
as quantity as quarantine may become
less essential uh as we see vaccination
uh programs accelerating losses here in
the uk which has been a fantastic effort
but across europe uh how we can address
that risk in the way which then allows
people to start traveling again
okay thank you very much for being on
the program um owen jones with air thank
you
well let's get a bit of a sense about
what it's really like to be experiencing
that hotel
quarantine because today marks 10 days
since the hotel quarantine policy was
introduced that means the first
travellers from 33 so-called redless
countries
have had to stay in a hotel after
arriving in the uk will be released
from today now elaine and wagner arauji
returned from brazil last tuesday after
visiting to attend to family business
they join us now from their hotel at
heathrow um good to see you good to see
you still
holding hands after being stuck in a
hotel together for so long
how has it been
it's been well it's been it's a good
time for us
to enjoy ourselves and uh
talk about uh our relationship and and
care about our families
uh yeah we spend a good time we decide
to
use this opportunity in our favor
and elaine how long exactly have you
been in the hotel for now
hey heyday so we're gonna come out on
friday unfortunately
because i we thought would be on
thursday but
the hotel just communicate with us and
saying that we
have must leave after
60 a.m on on friday
and what do you spend your days doing i
mean that's my big question i guess like
you're in
you're in the room the whole time is
that right and then you get room service
can you actually leave the room at all
yeah we have to arrange excuse me
we have to arrange an appointment with
the concierge
to come out and then the security will
come and knock out doors and take us to
the walk to walk and but
we left the room just once we
spent almost time inside the room
um all the time all the time actually
uh and then we play cards uh we watch tv
we you know we do exercise playstation
playstation and stuff watch movies
and you know talking too much
so yeah what we're doing at the moment
it sounds like you're um you know coping
pretty well with
all these activities that you're
managing to cram in i mean a lot of
people listening would probably think
you know
stuck with in a hotel room with your
partner for eight days you must have had
a few rounds as well or has it been okay
yeah wow but a long time is crazy but
yeah but we try to enjoy this time
try to use this time as our favorite set
and
get in trouble i know it's hard 10 days
we if we don't do different things we're
going to be crazy
yeah i can imagine you must be really
good at playstation by now
[Music]
[Laughter]
and how how how has it had an impact on
you
financially or did you factor in the
fact you were going to have to have
10 days in this hotel after your holiday
anyway
well uh we are trying to avoid to pay
this
amount of money try to come earlier but
as you couldn't we with nothing we can
do we just need to pay for it now
uh rules is the rule we need to live by
the rules
yeah but it's going to be a a little
impact on our financials
we oh yeah we're gonna you're gonna
survive at this
you're gonna get two of these okay well
well done for
um coping so well i hope you still got
enough pants to get you through the last
couple of days and
thanks so much for coming on the program
and explaining uh just what it's like
being trapped inside that hotel thank
you
you're welcome
now on to other news uh the prize for
young players who make the grade to join
the footballing elite
is a lavish lifestyle and the promise of
fame on potentially
a global scale but now sky news reports
on the fate of the
thousands of young footballers in club
academies up and down the country
who face rejection at a really
vulnerable age left with little
emotional support
and no guidance on what to do with the
rest of their lives here's our sports
correspondent
martha counter it's the career which so
many youngsters dream of
at any time around 12 000 boys and young
men are in football's youth development
system
fewer than 1 will ever make it to the
professional ranks
a sky news investigation has spoken to
many of those spat out by the system
one became a class a drug dealer another
flirted with gang life
they claim the academy setup is broken
leaving those rejected to deal with the
emotional fallout
ashley was released from fulham academy
at 19.
i went home and i waited for the
football club to contact me and help me
and that the help didn't come by the
time i was able to
look into it myself and try to forge out
something for myself it was too late a
lot of football clubs
weren't taking on players anymore and
that sent me into a
wild depression i honestly don't know
how we got through it
um i'm sorry
i found myself every single day before i
went to work
going into my son's room to check he was
breathing
i was taking days off work because i was
absolutely convinced that that was the
day he was going to take his life
fulham say they're investigating
ashley's claims but have so far
found nothing to support them the club
say they've contacted him on numerous
occasions
but are yet to receive a response
jeremy whiston shared the dream of
becoming a footballer
the 18 year old was found hanged in his
bedroom last october
he was his parents say devastated after
being released from manchester city
academy
jeremy's death has prompted soul
searching in football
ally plays for swansea under 23s and is
on the fringes of the first team
it's rare to hear a youngster still in
the system deliver a critical analysis
but ali's moral fiber runs deep
particularly when it concerns jeremy's
death
he was actually on trial at swansea a
few months before that
so on the day i found out what that was
i get goosebumps now just talking about
they were just
just stretching on the on the mat and
then you look at your phone and see
somebody's took their own life
and straight away you can relate to that
in the weirdest way possible because
that might sound it's not in a suicide
way but you can relate to them feelings
that that person has gone through
because you've been through them as well
charlton academy has a rich heritage of
bringing through
youngsters here they pride themselves on
their education programme
running regular player care sessions
focusing on preparing their players to
cope
in the event that football doesn't
become a career there's
always going to be
some sort of emotional fallout when a
player leaves a club
it's inevitable um especially if you've
got
a boy that's been with you for so long
some of these lads that i've known i've
known since they were eight nine years
of age
which is why it's absolutely incumbent
upon us again
to make sure that we engage with that
that mental
emotional well-being personal
development piece
when we can when they're here but with
each club allowed to register
up to 250 youngsters in their academy
and such a tiny number making it to the
top it's arithmetic which only makes
sense to the multi-billion pound
business
of football martha kellner sky news
education we're joined now by gauran
halahan a former teacher and senior
content writer
at the times educational supplement
thank you so much for being with us
we just heard from gavin williamson the
education secretary who didn't rule out
measures like lengthening the school day
or shortening the holidays to try and
help
children catch up do you think that
would be a good idea
well at the moment what we've heard so
far is just stage one so we're really in
the triage process
because what we need to do is wait for
the children to come back
see what their performance is like see
what the where the gaps actually
are and then we can decide whether
things like extending the school day
adjusting the school terms more serious
interventions are necessary what needs
to happen
first is for the children to return get
a sense of normality back again
see what we need to do and then make a
decision and how do you think
that return is going to go the
government wants to do all schools to
all pupils on the 8th of march
i mean is the testing capacity going to
be in place to do that
so the testing is going to be
particularly difficult before secondary
school students can start their
face-to-face teaching
they've got to have a negative result on
their lateral flow test
and this means getting all of the
students in and testing them
in a very short amount of time so that
8th of march start date is
quite unlikely for the secondary school
students because we're going to need
time to get them all tested first
and then after that first test lessons
can start and we need two more tests at
school which will be
more difficult more challenge for
schools to do and then after that
then the students can start testing at
home which should be much easier
i mean we're always reassured aren't we
that the testing capacity has gone up
but
it's hard not to forget what happened
last september when you know
universities went back when schools went
back
and the whole system was completely
overwhelmed are you worried that
the similar thing might happen
i think the key difference between
what's happening now
and what happened in september is that
we had that summer of
everything being relaxed we had lots and
lots of mixing we had students returning
after being abroad
whereas this time we've come we're going
back after a quite a serious lockdown
so we're hoping that perhaps the the
problems we had in the autumn
might not be quite as bad won't be
repeated again we've also got the fact
that in secondary schools
all students will be wearing masks
during lessons and we're hopeful that
this might help
reduce transmission too however the
really serious things that we know
does help stop transmission in schools
like
ventilation smaller class sizes that's
not being put in place
and we still know that teachers aren't
going to be prioritized for the
vaccinations
so although we're hopeful that things
might be a bit better i think we're
still feeling quite cautious
about what will actually happen when the
students go back yeah just to pick up on
teacher vaccination the government's
saying that look they're just following
the advice of the
jcbi the independent experts but at the
same time say there's around half a
million teachers
in england we're doing around three or
four hundred tested vaccinations a day
it'd just take a couple of days wouldn't
it for teachers to get their jobs
it does feel like that doesn't it it
seems that it would be quite an
easy thing to do we've had school mats
offer up their
their buildings to be like these super
centers where teachers can go and get
vaccinated
you know we wonder is this is this an
admin problem is it because it would be
too difficult
to vaccinate teachers to try and get
people to prove that they're
into evidence of their teachers to get
the vaccinations so it's quicker
just to go through the country by age i
don't know but we don't we
we do know that being vaccinated reduces
transmission we've seen that from the
reports from israel
so the justification before for not
vaccinating teachers was
that we don't know if it reduces
transmission it seems that now we do
so it does we don't understand why
they're not being vaccinated
i just want to ask you a little bit more
about the um
the attainment gap the progress that's
been lost over the last year and i know
it's very hard to
really calculate it uh the education
endowment foundation said that they
think
a decade of progress closing that gap
between the more disadvantaged and the
more privileged pupils could be wiped
out
how bad do you think the situation is
i think it's very difficult to make a
broad statement about what it's like for
all students because we've all had such
different experiences during lockdown
and although yes we can see that from
the statistics that
less advantaged students have been
engaging with their online work
less that doesn't necessarily mean that
when they come back into the classroom
they'll be further behind because of
course parents might be doing different
sorts of work with these children at
home
the simple answer is we just don't know
yet and we're not going to know until
the children are back
and we've got assessments being taken
place in school
we might not really know the full
picture until years to come
and we've of course got this
announcement from the government today a
bit more money to help schools
um really i guess deal with some of the
issues that you were just talking with
is that welcome
obviously we welcome the money it's a
little bit underwhelming at this stage
because it's not
quite as when you think how much it cost
to run a school
it it it pales in comparison but this is
just stage one and it sounds as if
there's more to come
we know that um sir kevin collins is
prioritizing not just the academic
development of students
but also their social and mental health
and it's
it's important that we see these these
measures as
part of a larger package that's going to
take place over a number of years
one of the concerns that we're hearing
um sir jeff barton
said that he sees it as a salami slice
the money is being carved up so much
that it might reduce its effectiveness
what we'd actually like to see is that
schools can have control over the money
and not have it
earmarked for for very specific things
to allow them to use their own knowledge
about their context
to spend the money in the most effective
way yeah i'm really glad you mentioned
mental health there as well
because it does feel like we talk a lot
about the academic impact but of course
there's going to be a big
mental health aspect to it too thank you
so much for coming
on the program sharing a bit of your
expertise with us this morning